video is circulating this evening after  a new district court judge became  quite emotional while sentencing a  repeat offender  the i-team has learned the offender 17  years old and has a  lengthy criminal history including eight  previous counts  for armed robbery now he was already on  probation but  was then charged as an adult i hope you  were listening to me  i hope this means something to you i  hope you see how hard it is  for me to do this to somebody as young  as you and i hope you  think about that every single day  because i will probably think about this  every single day for the rest of my life  judge baloo handed him two to five years  in the department of corrections  the judge previously was a public  defender in 2016 she wore a black lives  matter pin  in a courtroom a judge told her to  remove it and she refused  the i-team reached out to judge baloo no  comment was provided for this report